مقتل شخصين كل دقيقه جوعا في شرق افريقيا
ليس توقعات بل واقعا لا مهرب منه وفق
تحضير منظمه اوكسفام نبهت الى ان ازمه
الغذاء شرقيه افريقيا قد تصل الى ذروه
جديده في يوليو المقبل حيث يموت شخص جوعا
كل 28 ثانيه بين الحين والاخر اضافت ان
الجفاف الناجم عن المناخ والصراع المستمر
وارتفاع الاسعار للمواد الغذائيه تسبب
بمواجهه اكثر من اربعين مليون شخص لجميع
انحاء شرق افريقيا للجوع الشديد اي بزياده
قدرها نحو الثلثين على العام الماضي كما
رجحت معاناه مليونين ونصف المليون شخص
اضافي منعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد في
الاشهر المقبله بسبب التصعيد الاخير في
السودان علما بان نحو سته الاف لاجئ يفرون
يوميا الى جنوب السودان ما يشكل ضغطا
اضافيا على بلد يواجه نحو 63% من سكانه
بالف عل انعداما شديدا للامن الغذائي وهذا
اعلى مستوى في العالم اما عالميا فيواجه
حوالي
345 مليون شخص حاليا مستويات عاليه منعدام
الامن الغذائي حيث يبعد 43 مليون شخص خطوه
واحده عن المجاعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات